[Musique]
il
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du vip aujourd'hui on se
retrouve avec mary loket mairie je vais
commencer par vous présenter bonjour
bonjour vous vous appelez donc auquel
vous avez 24 ans originaire d'andrésy
dans les yvelines vous faites du para
babington puisque vous avez un handicap
à la main droite
et entre vous et la raquette c'est du
sérieux puisque six titres de champion
de france je crois et vous êtes 6e
mondial c'est actuellement exactement au
niveau du palmarès est ce que tu veux
vous pouvez me raconter un peu basses
oui six fois champion de france en
simple et en double je suis aussi double
vice-champion d'europe en 2016 et 2018
bac en simple et double aussi on va
commencer du coup parce qu'il ya occupé
pour beaucoup notre été beaucoup de fans
de sport cet été ont suivi les jeux
olympiques et les jeux paralympiques de
tokyo vous y êtes allé c'était comment
c'était fou j'ai adoré en fait c'était
un rêve d'enfant quand même je voulais
faire dans n'importe quel sport et je
les fais un peu tard 24 ans mais en
badminton et ça je suis trop posant vous
avez appris tardivement que vous avez
sélectionné s'est passé comment je
laisse eu un mois et demi avant quoi bon
tant mieux j'y vais mais c'était
difficile à préparer mon admiration
c'était plus difficile justement pour le
parcours que vous avez fait vous avez
fait trois matchs premier match remporté
contre le polonais bartlomiej bros que
je pense bien bonne entrée en matière du
coup comment c'était quoi le score
comment s'est passé le match c'est pas
trop dur justement de se mettre dans le
bain tout de suite en fait je me suis
dit quand je suis arrivé aux commandes
dit à l'aéroport à tokyo on a tout de
suite eu les les poules et là je tombe
sur cette foutue faits n'ont pas de
chance quoi parce qu'il ya le numéro un
numéro 3 et barques le polonais qui est
4e mondial et moi je suis 6 et là je me
suis dit ça j'ai pas de chance et où il
faut que je gagne ce match parce qu'en
fait c'est le champion d'europe aussi il
dit faut que j'y aille à fond et je suis
rentré dans une très grosse trans
vraiment jamais été comme ça pendant le
match et même lui après le match est
venu coiffer j'étais pas reconnu et où
tu m'a même pas dit bonjour avant le
match et où j'avais juste une une
obsession c'est de le battre
malheureusement après tout ne s'est pas
passé comme prévu puisque que vous avez
dit la poule était très relevé donc deux
défaites contre les indonésiens d'eva
henry mousty et souriau nous gros
c'était de ça a été dur pour vous de cet
effet tous non parce que de base moi je
devais pas aller au jeu c'était que du
bonheur c'était que du positif que
c'était l'option quoi et bon après je
vous contre le numéro un je voulais me
préserver un petit peu pour le dernier
match parce que je l'avais déjà battue
numéro 3 est malheureusement alors que
je suis en tête au score je me fais une
petite petite blessure à la cheville je
glisse sur sur une genre de plumes et
qui était mal nettoyé pas de chance et
je me blesse et je continue le match
mais trop douleur après ça a été la
rémission quand on entend ça et là bas
là j'ai repris il ya une semaine donc ça
fait un bon mois ni quoi je suis stopper
vous avez beaucoup parler justement de
toutes les émotions ressenties là bas
vous êtes passé par tous les états sais
je vous cite c'était une expérience qui
va vous servir par la suite c'est sûr
c'est sur moi je comprends pourquoi
maintenant on dit un sportif de haut
niveau il ya l'avant et après les jeux
dans la tête c'est façon des émotions
elles sont dues au x par dix et vu que
moi je suis passé j'ai gagné j'ai perdu
je me suis blessé j'ai pas su au dernier
fin j'y suis au dernier moment que j
allais il ya eu tout tout tout tout est
du coup baisse pour paris 2024 eh ben je
pense que c'est une très bonne chose
justement on reviendra sur vos objectifs
mais du coup qu'est ce que ça fait de
porter les couleurs de la france dans
finalement la plus prestigieuse des
compétitions
basse et c'est dingue il n'y avait pas
de public non ça change pas trop puisque
opara aidant badminton on va dire en
europe c'est pas très médiatisé mais
mais on a senti cette ferveur du coût
des yvelines de ma ville d'andrésy des
personnes qui sont sur place qui suivit
par les réseaux et c'était d'équipé
puisque du coup il y avait que ça et
il y avait que de la positivité c'était
ouf j'ai adoré justement c'est à tokyo
donc dans le continent du badminton la
basse et c'est les champions de l'iphone
sont des dieux vivants près ce qu'on
peut dire
c'est vous aimeriez que ce soit pareil
en france a bien sûr bien sûr qu'on
aimerait que ce soit pareil mais quand
même aujourd'hui mais est-ce que ça
évolue à kiel rhein statut du
franchement ouais ouais bah ça a évolué
parce qu'on fait des bons résultats
on performe quand même à l'international
la france n'est pas un mauvais pays en
bad en par abad en valide c'est
différent il ya un peu moins de bons
résultats en pareils on est vraiment
très bon et ça c'est parce qu'on a un
très bon groupe il ya une fédération qui
nous suit bien les coaches tous sont son
top et soissons on est on est assez
soudé pour un sport à dire individuel il
ya un collectif qui est cool et on peut
que performer comme ça et donc prochain
objectif paris 2024 prochain gros
objectif bien sûr à la maison comment ça
se prépare ça se prépare dès aujourd'hui
je ne serai pas ça se commence à se
préparer dans la tête ça se prépare
surtout sur la planification des
entraînements de caisse qui va nous
entraîner jusqu'à cette échéance qui est
hyper importante les préparateurs
physiques les kinés l'arrêt cul ça se
prépare dès maintenant mais d'ici là du
coup d'autres compétitions on peut
attendre d'autres titres de champion de
france comment vous voyez les trois
prochaines années bon allez trois
prochaines années je l'espère je serai
encore champion de france les trois
prochaines années quand même ça veut
dire que je suis numéro en france est
donc potentiellement
que je vais au jeu et là les
championnats français en janvier à côté
de cholet dans
l'eure-et-loir après 90 d'accord je sais
pas si vous
voilà en janvier du coup on va revenir
un peu sur votre cas maintenant puisque
vous allez découvrir le badminton à
l'âge de 17 ans un retour votre handicap
ce handicap de naissance s'appelle une
agénésie trans carpien voilà qu'est ce
que c'est exactement en gros c'est
simple c'est ma main aller comme ça dans
le ventre de votre maman quoi et ce
jusque là oublié de se développer à
l'oublier perte de mémoire oui enfin
c'est le manque de développement des
trans carte des doigts voilà c'est tout
mais par rapport au badminton comme
c'est un sport qui joue à une main c'est
quand même il ya quand même des en fait
le seul on va dire ce qui est difficile
c'est que de bas je suis droitier quand
même donc j'ai dû apprendre thème de la
gauche donc il ya des petits réflexes
qui reste l' équilibre au sivu qui a
j'ai quand même moins de muscles d'un
côté que de l'autre et aussi je suis
droitier de la jambe je suis droitier
bras et jambes donc j'ai dû les appuis
france transporté tout ça à gauche et
c'est ça s'est fait plutôt bien
heureusement que ce n'est pas un
accident parce que avec vous le disais
justement que dans votre catégorie c les
asus 5 je crois il ya beaucoup de
gauchers en fait finalement oui oui oui
il ya beaucoup de gauchers il ya un peu
de droitier mais parce que souvent si
des accidents de la vie il ya quand même
beaucoup de personnes qui sont comme moi
avec deux naissances et
façon c'est beaucoup plus simple de
naître avec un handicap que d'un coup
d'un jour au lendemain tu te réveilles
et on doit tout apprendre à 15 16 ans
c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour les
autres membres vous jouez souvent avec
des valises puisque dans votre club
notamment
vous faites des compétitions avec les
valides c'est surtout je fais des
compétitions avec les valides je les
fais rang national au niveau national
mais parce que voilà il ya quand même
une différence entre le valide et le
para et en plus j'ai commencé assez tard
donc c'est aussi pour ça sinon y'aurait
pas de différence mais oui je m'entraîne
avec des valises puisque moi j'ai mes
jambes je peux les utiliser et souvent
le battre c'est quand même un sport de
vitesse on a besoin de beaucoup des gens
donc justement quel style de joueur à
moi je suis très agressif mois moi
j'aime bien un peu vif agressif latin
l'attaquent l'attaquent direct je suis
papa passif la gêne pas trop sagement
d'or après
elle donc le badminton ça a commencé à
17 ans pour vous avant c'était le judo
c'est ça comment ça a changé que quel a
été le déclic alors le déclic s'est fait
par un ami qui faisait du bad qui est en
équipe de france valide et en fait moi
j'avais toujours cet objectif dans ma
tête de dire je fais du sport pour le
dépassement de soi et moi je pensais que
les sports de combat c'est ce qu'il y
avait de plus dur à l'entraînement et au
final on m'a dit viens on essaye le bad
comme tout le monde bat sports de plage
voilà je fais ça à la plage tranquille
et j'ai fait deux trois entraînements et
là mais maintenant quand je m'entraîne
je rentre je dors je suis ko je suis
mort j'ai besoin d'entraînement par
semaine je m'entraîne un peu près
je pense quatre heures 4 heures par jour
donc quatre à cinq heures est-ce que
toujours des petites attaches au judo
finalement aussi genre toujours toujours
vous suivez les championnats vous étiez
léger aussi bien sur votre idole teddy
riner
mais ouais bah c'est carrément le judo
c'est mon enfance quoi et vous avez
d'autres idoles comme ça d'autres images
auxquelles vous inspirer ou franchement
teddy riner s'est tous avouent que après
je fais pas trop gaffe apprécié mais
j'aime bien conor mc gregor ça rien à
voir mais sports de combat aussi vrai
sinon à des badistes joueurs de
badminton que vous suivez en asie je
suis fan fan nan que je suis non oui
mais après c'est moins développés c'est
moi développer un bon peu moins c'est
difficile de suivre les compétitions
c'est assez difficile de les suivre
visuellement à la télé c'est vrai mais
par contre quand tu es en asie et tout
c'est eux c'était super star ac comme dé
cristiano ronaldo ici raison des statuts
dans l'hydrolien c'est un truc de fou
les gens ne se balade pas avec des
t-shirts de fautes ils se baladent avec
des t-shirts de bad en chine c'est comme
ça c'est un truc de fou et on va aussi
finir enfin nous reste quelques minutes
mais parler de des attaches avec les
yvelines puisque vous avez grandi dans
la ville d'andrésy et je crois savoir
que vous gardez de fortes attaches avec
la ville avec notamment des réunions
avec le maire là on rentre en tokyo vous
aviez aussi un accueil qui a été fait ça
très bien j'ai reçu par la ville
d'andrésy un an toute surprise je ne
savais pas que j'allais avoir ça la
ville à la médaille de la ville j'étais
hyper content parce que parce que je
suis c'est ma ville de coeur et je suis
très content de donner pour eux je fais
beaucoup d'interventions dans l'est dans
le collège dans l'est dans les petites
les primaires auprès des jeunes faire de
la sensibilisation un peu de parler un
peu du handicap du sport de haut niveau
souvent il ya des enfants qui sont un
peu recroquevillés sur eux ça peut faire
du bien de parler et de voir sur tout et
ça j'adore j'adore intervenir c'est
c'est hors de ses importants de son ouïe
de transmettre vos valeurs finalement
oui
pour cette raison justement c'est ça
pour cette raison justement vous avez
j'ai vu commencer à être entraîneur
aussi a aussi engendré zik comment ça se
passe justement les débuts en tant
qu'entraîneur aussi alors j'ai quelques
petits diplômes quand même d'entraîneur
quelques années parce qu'avant je
m'entraînais plus ça à bourges et j'ai
entraîné là bas et donc du coulage en
train d p tit donc c'est très marrant
surtout petit quand c'est quelqu'un tu
es gorille ils ont entre je pense entre
5 et 9 ans d'accord 5,9 récents pour
inculquer les bases en fait exactement
les appeler un bon let's go voyages
jonage finalement qu'on apprend vite
ouais ben je leur fait aimer le sport
entre guillemets pas que le baiia le
sport en général ça qui est cool et du
coup par rapport à andrésy vous
continuez de d'entretenir fin vous vous
voyez comme ça continuer jusqu'à la fin
de votre carrière ou quand une même
après à entretenir les relations avec
les élus n'ont pas de toute façon faut
s'entendre avec le plus de monde
possible je fais pas non mais oui je
m'entends hyper bien pour l'instant ça
se passe super bien il m'aide à avoir
des créneaux pour que je m'entraîne
c'est ça aussi ils m'ont aidé à avoir
une subvention une bourse notamment 200
euros qui a été débloqué pour préparer
pour les jeux pour les jeux olympiques
et c'était pour ça que ans en
contrepartie j'étais obligé j'avais
envie de façon de devenir faire des la
présence dans les écoles et tous étaient
trop cool ça aujourd'hui le badminton
c'est on va finir là-dessus c'est
qu'elle place dans votre vie vous êtes
professionnel joueur professionnel de
badminton ou c'est quand même difficile
on va dire de vivre que de ça comment
alors je suis joueur professionnel
mais c'est quand même difficile d'en
vivre professionnelle parce qu'en fait
il pour être les meilleurs et dans ma
catégorie c'est très proche du valide
haut niveau le niveau
il faut s'entraîner quatre heures 5
heures par jour et tu peux pas vraiment
travailler à côté en tout cas à plein
temps et en plus quand tu finis tes
entraînements de base je vous dis c'est
très très difficile c'est que tu es
morte et tu peux pas être très lucide
après si tu travailles sur un tir sur un
quelque chose de concret quoi donc pour
être
bien il faut ouais mais après il faut
chercher des sponsors et salue le plus
difficile plus difficile c'est d'avoir
la casquette d'athlètes et la casquette
de je vends un peu mon corps me cascio
de comme pour dire voilà je peux
transmettre des bonnes valeurs et tout
est bien merci beaucoup de rien le club
d'avoir été avec nous je vous souhaite
du coup le meilleur pour la suite de
leur carrière en espérant aussi reçu une
médaille à paris 2024 oui et donc c'est
la fin de ce vip à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]